now these quick hitches that we sell
here good works tractors the spikos
these red ones here
they're going to be good for everything
from a big 40 66r about as big of a
compact tractor as you can get
all the way down to a little subcompact
like this 1025r the great thing about
these speako quickhitches is that they
don't use bushings okay so
this little slot here is designed to be
a direct fit with your category 1 your 7
8 pin that goes right in here a lot of
the other quick hitches out there
require you to stack on
a category 3 bushing there's no real
point of that besides spending more
money
we can ship these all over the country
to you now let's get to that tip of the
week
this was a real scenario that happened
with a customer recently that just
purchased a quick hitch and went to hook
up to their frontier rototiller
it wasn't matching up so this isn't
going to take care of every problem
that's out there but this is going to be
a common thing found on things like
rototillers could be a sweep all
like what we have right here i want to
show you what it is so if you go ahead
and you're backing up your tractor with
the quick hitch to mate up
okay with the pins you got two lower
pins for your three point then you got
the top middle
so if your alignment with your bolt pins
right here are not equal to the quick
hitch spacing take a look and see if
this lower bracket is welded or bolted
on
in this case here you can see it's going
to be bolted on and what that allows you
to do
is loosen up the bolts slide this thing
in or out same thing with the other side
you still want to maintain an equal
amount of spacing on both sides of the
center pin back up accordingly get your
center line for your quick hitch here
and then just loosen it up see where you
got to be center it and then you can go
ahead and tighten these bolts back down
really quick while we're bolting this
lower link on let me tell you all about
this sweep all here this is a lawn
sweeper on steroids okay you're going to
see it's pto
driven it's going to have an electric
dump from the seat bagger that's on here
foam filled tires quick hitch compatible
it comes in 48 or 60 inch wide
increments there i'm gonna have a lot
more information coming out about this
going over a product overview as well as
a lot of
field test videos of this thing it picks
up walnuts pine cones
leaves aeration plugs the list just goes
on and on
nice good call
well hopefully you found this helpful we
gotta finish setting up this sweetball
sweepster here
and get it ready to go but it's not
gonna solve every single compatibility
issue there with a quick hitch but it's
something to take a look at
again this customer called in they
weren't sure what was going on there the
frontier was supposed to be quick hitch
compatible
the quick hitch is built to a standard
specification there's no variation there
besides this a fraction of an inch which
isn't going to matter so
take a look see if you have adjustable
lower links on there that could solve
the problem you're having
if you like what you see here hit that
like button and subscribe as well that
would really help me out
read through that description below
there's going to be all sorts of helpful
links for where you can buy this quick
hitch the sweetball
all sorts of cool stuff for tractor
owners now we got to finish putting this
thing together here before the sun goes
down
until next time stay safe we'll see you
[Music]
soon
is it on yeah i didn't hear an action
action
we're shooting the same view though the
whole time
well right way to do it
because it could be as simple as simply
sliding your pin in or out left to right
are you worried about saying sliding
did i yeah thank you those are good
catches
i don't know what's going on